foreign
to another awesome episode of Lake
careful boys and today we have a Jason
Cheney back with us
a question yes of all time thank you
guys so much for having me looking at me
well you're the host man look at look at
them okay I'm gonna look at them too but
can I not look at you okay fine what is
the problem right now there's no problem
um I'm just trying to what do you think
about you being like the most requested
just to come back number one how do you
feel about that number one
Anthony yeah okay that's number one okay
number two
um number two
I don't think you need to pick that up
I wouldn't actually number two I forgot
number two because you did it the quick
thing
how did you spell that out it's k-u-h
k-u-k-e that's onomatopoeia
yeah so will you question again please
uh I was just saying how do you how does
that make you feel to know that you're
oh no I really requested that's why I
said I I really appreciate you guys
having me every time
she didn't want you here yeah I'll
accept it why don't you love me here why
wouldn't I want you here why don't you
want me here because he said that I
didn't say that yeah I think I think
that's what it is
not because Colleen oh here we go Nick
what's a hoe and she she doesn't watch
the show so she doesn't know that I
don't watch the show we're really not
here I'm taking this to my heart uh now
I'm insulted and I'm gonna make Jason
Chang I watch it sometimes you do oh we
do actually yeah I was watching the one
with the the mayor that married the
crocodile and do you laugh at your own
jokes no turn it off
Nick is a comedic timing genius
I think they're wrong and they don't
watch enough comedy I think that's
they're just not really well versatile
good timing the the way that you said
that yeah I would say though but back to
Jason Cheney and how Colleen doesn't
want to be here
just turn up
back to Jason Cheney
and how you share penis pictures that
was new information yeah it's because I
like um that is new information and it's
good information and it's a secret
but not anymore because everyone knows
well it's the secret the fact that um I
just feel maybe for the penis showers
out there that
um it's a small group of people like
maybe how many people you think in
California
showers like sex offenders
well it's like uh it's not consensual
it's more of a surprise but so okay okay
oh no no no but but it's a surprise but
like flashers can I say some stuff too
okay it doesn't work like that here
okay what the thing is
um if you meet somebody and you feel
comfortable enough like in the moment
it's like a kiss you know how on the
first day you you kiss a you know
what the [ __ ]
get the angles
what's warm up it's a Sunday this is
God's day this is God's day it's like a
it's a level of friendship yeah you can
reach yeah
so it's like the first kiss you don't
know when it's gonna come but then when
it comes it's a surprise when it comes
as a funny sentence to use
um the context what we were just talking
about before the camera was wrong with
how he was I know it's a secret but you
were talking about how you and Pat Riley
was showing each other your penises yeah
right yeah
and you're just talking about how you're
like you're like hey I want to see your
dick because you said it to me and I was
like well that's weird
and then you were like oh but I was like
I've shown my penis and then you brought
it Pat Riley it's secret but he's been
here before and then you're just like
yeah we we just showed each other our
dick yeah so and then we were like what
you didn't say that you're like me too I
did not say me too is this over FaceTime
and then she said that's what everybody
says and then she said says she's a
grower wow
[Laughter]
[Music]
Anthony just putting words in people's
mouth yeah why are you putting words in
your own mouth better put words word and
mouths than other things that we're
talking about dude you put lies
you're overpowering with your volume and
and it's it's diminishing my that's
about really the story that you were
telling me so so uh Pat Riley good
friend big penis
so I we're FaceTiming I love him and
then so I was like you want to see my
penis and before he said something I was
like you know and then he's like whoa
and then uh I was like okay now you know
like like an airplane yeah Bart loves
airplanes that's the airport wow and
then where were you you're in your room
or your wife is next to you or oh
probably but it doesn't matter I just
she knows she knows that she knows that
outside like that
question is Patrick one of the only guys
you show your penis to like consensual
oh no I showed it to uh David David so
too and what did David Sosa he said I
really like it I would like it on Monday
Wednesday and Friday and then did he did
he reciprocate did he show you back his
no I've been asking for it you showed
him in person no I showed him uh I
wasn't playing it
than that I go hey how's your day and
then I go you saw that like that you saw
that not like you felt it did you see it
you feel what reaction are you searching
for that makes you feel good you know
what it is it's just that okay if if
you're gonna show me because remember
the Ana thing I just I always show my
penis to my roommate I never did that
there but you go ahead
forever really
yeah some people did that remember how
everybody does that at that school
that's very normal I feel like yeah it
is because it's like I understand that
school is crazy yeah yeah so you just
show it but were you shown it all the
time she's not gonna I don't feel like
you're gonna show people I wouldn't show
penis so that's receive it so that's
this this is the interesting thing right
at this school like I was saying it's
like jail Asians hang out with the
Asians white black whatever and then all
the like the little thugs they all hang
out with each other
and then so when you walk by like let's
say the white parts of the dorm
that's the kind of [ __ ] you hear through
the oh shoot [ __ ] did I show you
my dick
[Laughter]
put my helmets butt naked from the
shoulders down just running down the
hallway yeah that's their [ __ ] right you
walk by the [ __ ] Asian parts of the
dorm everyone's [ __ ] Asian squats
smoking cigarettes so it's like you're
gonna say they were studying
those are the average Asians we sent the
bad ones this is a very delinquent
school this is very confusing is it very
delinquent School even when you guys
share stories about like your Naval
Academy experiences yours seems very
different than Bart so he hung out with
the other people yeah Bartz was more of
gang fights you had fights too but it
was a lot of like he's on the ground
pillow you know like stuff like that
it's a different class of participants
yeah it's that means it's uh diverse
that's good so you've been chilling
peanuts since that position since uh
yeah I've been passing it on since the
school and it because if you don't want
to see it then I would want to show you
more but not not in the [ __ ] not like
a Harvey Weinstein not in now Ryan think
it is right now not not like how it
sounds it's just it sounds exactly like
how yeah yeah I don't understand me man
oh don't bulldoze me again but it's also
to mostly oh I'm saying I'm assuming
it's mostly men you're doing this too
I'm going to get out of that lady yeah
that never women I don't even want to
show women my penis it's not even fun
okay so I'll leave the room and uh you
guys handle it you guys need a handle or
just tilt you're happy you know we're
just gonna just put on airplane mode so
if you show someone your opinion no no
no no with what he said we're closer but
if you've chose someone your penis and
they don't show you their penis it's
fine oh it's fine to you but it's I
would feel a little sad then you're not
close so were you sad when David didn't
show you his penis were you a little sad
um do you feel more distant yeah
he's just Out Of Reach
what's happening right now I'm just
asking an honest question because it's
like a first kiss you said right so yeah
for the first kiss the other person
doesn't kiss you back yeah yeah and it's
like a secret right I don't know I keep
on saying stupid it's more like like a
comfortableness thing like I love when
other people are comfortable enough
around me to share either like a real
secret or their physical secret what if
I show you my ass and stuff
like it was one hand before and now it's
too good he upgraded dude yeah
sure not a girl what you're offering Ash
instead of Dick how would you feel if
someone showed you their butt cheeks
instead well that's stupid what I don't
want to see you so that's dumb yeah
that's dumb so like show me your [ __ ]
that's intimate that is intimate it's
like it's something that you don't feel
comfortable I get your logic yeah if you
don't feel comfortable and you're like I
will want to show you but not everybody
else yeah then I feel special I don't
even show my wife my [ __ ] that's what
I'm saying
when I was in junior high I had a friend
named Christian that's a funny
interviews
um and he he was like hey you want to
see a fruit cup do you know what fruit
cup is I never heard of a fruit yeah
okay so Fruits Basket there's different
names yeah but it's the same thing you
can understand it as is but I was like
uh I was like what fruit cup you want to
see your fruit cup I was like sure and
then he just [ __ ] pulled his penis
down he turns around but he's covering
his butthole and he's holding his
schlong just so that he can I could see
the back of his scrotum oh oh is that is
that the right way to decide I think I
saw a different thing
the thing that the guys would do is you
you tuck your dick and balls like
backwards oh yeah so then it looks like
you have a vagina and then you turn you
turn around and bend over and it looks
like a basket of fruit
that's what I saw that's what I saw yeah
I blacked out half of it but I think
that's what that's still disgusting
stuff their chicks do with each other
yeah
oh you know when you're facing something
with girls you don't just go you don't
go like hey you want to see a loaf of
bread and try to squeeze your titties
we don't have those kind of Secrets oh
my God maybe that's how you build deep
rooted relationships right right women
you guys are more comfortable with uh
like showing each other your physical
with baked goods yeah oh yeah yeah
without making a joke out of it that's
true without yeah I think oh like it's a
mature and fine thing yeah mature that's
it's like yours like so supportive like
oh my God look at your elbows your tits
right now I want to sleep yes I want to
see the humor of like if someone was
calling you FaceTime and then you go
like this and then you answer it and the
first thing that's not funny to women I
mean it's funny to me there you go or if
they go well yeah it's way more funnier
with that sound effect yeah yeah
have you found that you've had uh
relationships with any chicks that like
you've like this is this is normal
Anthony don't hold it with me
you're gaslighting people this is a
[ __ ] conversational talk show like we
discuss things I think
so many syllables in one word geez
that's really hard for there are women
that are that like kind of Crash and
having that sense of humor but it's
probably hard for them to find someone
just like that you think chicks in the
WNBA are like that
look at look at my basketball shorts wow
yeah like like you know it just I feel
like it's more in line never mind maybe
I think there's maybe there is a higher
chance that there's more wnb people have
that same defect we do not even WNBA
just like women's sports teams you think
they're more likely to be horse around
like this probably lock it's locker room
type humor right well I mean to be fair
I did experience this
um
we were at a party and uh we were like
in this room there was a mirror and
there's like a few girls in that room
and she just takes off her top and she's
looking at her boobs and she's like I
kind of want them to be more like this
and this and so we were like talking
about like what she would want to do to
her boobs I've I've seen that yeah but
it's never in like but it's constructive
it's constructive there's like a purpose
right it's not like this cranky nature
yeah there's no Frankie nature there
where's the fun
where's the fun I would love to see like
a woman lady with uh the [ __ ] with with
like you'd be like look at my hamburger
yeah
[Laughter]
okay all right or what you could do is
like instead of that situation where
you're like oh I wish my tits were like
this or whatever like you're about to do
that and all the girls know that like oh
she's probably gonna do some comparison
for her tits but then you lift up your
top and there's like googly eyes or
something
just like prop it up
yeah dude and then she's been prepping
all morning for that one I can't wait
till I have an opportunity to do this
can you imagine if you you had it saved
up like that and then you died in the
corners all what the [ __ ]
but like you think if you did that so
many questions
if you think you did that and then like
a woman's locker room do you think that
would get a laugh or do you think
everyone first of all for like the whole
day she'll be walking around
or like one would fall off and I'd have
to like yeah but you you prep it right
before okay I know I feel like that
wouldn't get a laugh but I wouldn't get
a laugh no no but in a guy's locker room
that's [ __ ] hilarious if you had
googly eyes on your screws come on dude
or you put on your nips oh my God that's
hilarious you know so you should just
try and just test it out for us come
back
I was in those same locker room settings
it's like I remember when guys would
play like basketball in the court and
then for no reason somebody would just
take a ball and just Chuck it at another
oh dude yeah in high school that's funny
good times everybody used to die
laughing because you know you have to
take showers in high school like they
mandatory make you do it so like we
would protest it by just [ __ ] around
in the showers and the coach would be
like stop messing around and then I
started doing uh backspins super
freaking fast butt naked yeah butt naked
yeah super butt naked yeah laughs dude I
was a hit yeah you're the king of the
[ __ ] build the ball I got prom King
right there in the spot what what is it
about dudes that like to [ __ ] around
like that and we think it's one of the
first things I ever did I was five years
old in kindergarten during nap time it's
it's okay to put my dick from the
[ __ ] bathroom like penises are
extremely ugly yeah it's just like weird
things it's just they're so weird it's
yeah so they have to be funny otherwise
it's just horrendous oh my God I can't
imagine you spinning with your penis
like a helicopter out there like hey
thanks I can't imagine I'm sure thank
you thanks for giving me that that
credit I was just imagining but
especially like when you're doing like
spins like in your penis that's funny
yeah that's hilarious that's funny so
skillful it's guy to guy humor it's like
do you know your demo would Nina find
that funny if she comes home and you're
spinning on the floor naked you don't do
that for girls you do that for other
guys
what are you doing what do you think she
would say
if I first of all I'd be impressed if I
could spin that fast probably Dominique
prom King right there with hydroplaning
on water you will spin yeah get the
floor all wet the living room what would
she say if I was spinning butt naked on
my back super fast but you prepped it
like babe I have a great surprise for
you
[Laughter]
what would you do if you were spinning
really fast butt naked I can't spend
really fast butt naked but I have like
held it
German and Swinging like that oh
helicopter yeah yeah how do you feel
about that
um and when do you do that what are your
best moves do you show that to people do
you go well
like a helicopter
[Laughter]
you know whatever you did
but yeah I feel like
I feel
she doesn't like it
it's not funny so you do Nina doesn't
have that kind of humor like she doesn't
find stuff like that funny so of course
she fought at this point oh she does but
you know that's because I'm I'm a funny
person when I'm butt naked you know what
I mean that's just my natural comedic
self of course it's funny but show us
some moves when I do it okay so uh but
you probably can't do it every day it's
gonna get old right the most recent
thing that she really okay this is so
dumb that I'm sure you just can't
believe I'm sure this the most recent
thing that I did that she actually like
cracked up and really really enjoyed uh
I called uh idj right it's called
infinite dick Jutsu right it's uh it's
an anime Jutsu type thing and it's
basically when you go up to
um uh those closets that have a mirror
like a standing mirror on each side of
the doors so that you could look down
like they you know like Bruce Lee under
the dragon you see infinite version of
yourself okay and then you just go in
there and you start whacking your dick
around but you could see a million
penises
yeah I called the infinite picture too
she loved it and it was a hit that is
actually pretty good that's the stand in
between the specific spot though so it's
funnier because she's gotta like not be
in the way but lean over me so she could
still see in the same plane of you it's
really good it's a [ __ ] Kaleidoscope how
do you invite somebody to to see that
you once you figure it out you're like
hey come here come here I got a trick
for you oh okay wow but he she he's
already known at the house for like his
Antics with his penis
you are yeah oh wow you said that's one
of your your natural States is like when
you yeah it's on your LinkedIn like your
known for this in the home like you have
a repertoire it's a secret
only only need a Pat Riley know
so it's a good time it's a good time so
you don't do this stuff with your wife
you don't show her like your dick
um does that ever get a laugh with her I
don't
not really
she heckles you why do you say it like
you just survived yeah yeah
or a cool thing to to
um bring to the surface is how guys bond
by showing their dicks it's kind of
funny yeah I can't believe this turned
into that but not everybody though
as privileged to get that close to
another man well sometimes like I
wouldn't Nick maybe Anthony and
um maybe my name is Ryan no no no I know
you're here
[Laughter]
oh no I'm just thinking that I might not
um I might not show you immediately I
might show you like later in like
because you just see more um a little
more nice
foreign